[Music]
[Applause]
we bring in one of the great
broadcasters of all time Hall of Fame
Amazon Thursday Night Football
play-by-play boys Al Michaels joining us
on the program
Al thanks for joining us when I say the
name Vin Scully what comes to mind
one of a kind
uh nobody like him
can't imagine there will be anybody like
him in the future it's a it's a
different template now
of any of those 67 years
did most of the games by himself
uh he had a partner Jerry Doggett for a
number of years but then he would do
seven Innings by himself and the jury
would do two
and then in the latter years Vinnie
would do six Innings on television maybe
three on radio or nine innings on TV
when you think about it
how many people have a job any job or
work for 67 consecutive years
or have the same job for 67 consecutive
years
and bring it bring it every day not only
did I move to Los Angeles when the
doctors moved here but I was in Brooklyn
and we lived within walking distance to
Evans field and the first thing in my
life that can ever remember is walking
in that shield with my father
when I was six or seven and Vinnie was
maybe in his first or second year with
the Dodgers
and just falling in love with the
atmosphere with baseball my father said
that's where the guys who were
announcing the game are are in that
broadcast Booth up there I looked up
there and that was the first thing I
ever remember and that made me want to
get into broadcasting so
there's no question Vinnie was was my
very early Idol I tried to emulate him
when I got the Hawaii Islander job uh my
first professional job doing minor
league baseball in 68 I'm flying over
there and the only thing I'm thinking on
the plane then is just sound like Vinnie
I'm very nervous I'm starting my career
and I did sound like Vinnie I sounded
like a mini clone for so many years and
then of course I was able to um you know
bring my own style to it but there was
always a lot of Vinnie in me and I knew
him and I can only tell you Dan that if
if it was a a contest where best
baseball announcer of all time and it
was a horse race Vinnie was Secretariat
winning the Belmont by 31 Lanes
you remember the first time you met him
I do uh I actually met him
he was on vacation in Hawaii
when I was doing the Islanders there was
the off-season I was living there full
time and I was doing uh the local sports
on television and I knew he was at the
at that time the Kahala Hilton and I
just called the room and I was very
nervous and I said hi Mr Scully I'm Al
Michaels and I'm on television here uh
would you mind if I came down with a
camera and you know talked to you for a
couple of minutes oh sure is that how
many put it and uh I I went down there
and I was I was so nervous uh and and he
was great and he remembered it not that
many years later when I'm doing the
Cincinnati Reds and my first year with
the red so good the Big Red Machine I've
got Rose and bench and Perez and Morgan
would come the next year and our first
trip to La Vinnie asked me to go on the
pregame show Dodger warm-up and that was
one of the great Thrills of my life I
listed that show from the time I was a
child and Vinnie's interviewing me on
the radio it was something I'll never
forget
you talked about that style
that if you came up with that style now
that I can't imagine a TV or radio
executive is going to go well yeah come
on in you know you're gonna you're gonna
do the game by yourself okay yeah not
gonna happen
yeah you might have to yell a little bit
more to win the audition yeah gotta have
a catchphrase or two and you oh or or
Ken or you know or be or be dude perfect
and come onto Amazon and do the awesome
telecast you know
I mean God bless everybody
I think so just a little bit times yeah
but you know but Vinnie Vinnie was
forever and even at the end of his
career and and you know he ended it in
the 2016. great honor for me they were
honoring Vinnie on opening day and they
asked me to come and see it and bring
out all the the Dodgers and uh and all
the people who were close to him he um
he was at the end of his career and as I
said he brought it every day because
through the years they had a lot of
great teams and some bad teams but I
would be driving home from wherever
um you know seven eight years ago being
get to the driveway open up the garage
door and then if any was telling a story
I would just stop let the car idle and I
had to hear the rest of the story he was
that good for 67 years it's just
impossible nobody could nobody could
ever duplicate that nobody but also he
did other sports
you know did football he did golf uh he
did game of the week with baseball
um yeah but to be able to tell those
stories and radio is different than TV
as you well know TV Your Role is to
complement what we get to see radio I
gotta create everything so to be able to
do that
the same broadcast that's going to be on
TV and on radio
is kind of a that's a double header
that's that's tricky to pull off very uh
you know you mentioned sure Kern chick
did that a chick that a simulcast so
chick did uh radio and TV both and had
to do basically a radio broadcast
because if you were doing a television
broadcast on radio the radio listener
was going to miss a lot uh so there was
it was probably overly wordy but
basketball lent itself to being overly
wordium and the game is a fast-paced
game uh as opposed to what baseball is
but Vinnie was able to Vinnie made the
transition perfectly uh he knew how to
you know work both mediums
with he was so descriptive obviously on
on radio and radio that you use every
you know verb in the dictionary
television you're doing a lot of
captions and speaking in ellipses uh uh
you're feeling I mean the verb is visual
you can see it's a line drive it's a pop
flight whatever it is
uh Benny knew how to do it perfectly he
was he was phenomenal at that and uh as
I say I can't think of anybody anybody
like him could it happen again among
other things you know that now teams
have eight nine ten announcers guys have
you know 38 days off and all of that for
so many years Vinnie did 162 games in
every Every Spring Training Game and
they got to the playoffs and World
Series a lot so if any did everything
all the time and uh how his voice even
held up was amazing and you mentioned he
did other sports I'll never forget he
told me once he said he was always
hesitant to do that he said because if
you're on too much
people won't miss you but if you if you
just do the right amount they can't wait
for you to get back I understood that uh
and and you know during the years when
some of us in the business would be
doing would be doing so many things it's
like at a certain point you know people
are going to go him again you know so
Benny was always very very
cognizant of that I think I need to take
a couple of months off of that now
because I've been doing it every single
day for for a long long time uh Thursday
night football with Kirk Herbstreit uh
right what is the one thing that you uh
you want answered this upcoming season
what would be the question you would
have going into this season
well we just had a three-day seminar and
they they really uh brought together a
pretty amazing group of people uh and
Kirk and I you know we haven't worked
together but we're going to do a
practice game here in Los Angeles uh
before we do a regular
preseason game in Houston at the end of
uh at the end of August and then the
Chargers in Kansas City it's going to
work I mean Kirk is usually prepared
Fred gadelli is our producer I've worked
with for 21 years Pierre Musa has a lot
of experience the director we bring in
Kaylee Horton who's done Sports in the
past and she's going to do the sideline
uh our support people are are really
really good
um and I think that you know you can't
reinvent the wheel the game is the game
the game is the most important thing and
the other day you know when I had to get
up and talk a little bit at the seminar
I said hey look at the game is a star
and we're all here and we've got a it's
a pretty eclectic and very interesting
pre-game task we have with Akeem Talib
and Richard Sherman and and uh Andrew
Whitworth uh Tony Gonzalez Carissa
Thompson uh they were up there the other
day and then they put they put on a
little bit of a show that was fantastic
I gotta tell you so um I'm going to be
very interested to see how that works
out you got the alternate fees with dude
perfect uh and and God knows what else
we're gonna have coming along but you
know Dan when it comes down to it
the huge majority of the audience the
vast majority they want to watch the
game yeah so am I going to be different
doubtful
can I be better you know you can tweak
it Fred godelli and I every year we we
do a press tour and the Press would
always say what are you going to do
that's different and I would say no the
question is what are you going to do
that's better how do you enhance it how
do you make it how do you make it better
uh it's as simple as that but you don't
do that by changing the whole template
you can't at this point well the game is
what changes you don't change the game
changes because it's you know it's a
different game every single week
um can you Embrace gambling more on the
broadcast now than maybe in previous
years on NBC
yes but you know you don't want to
overdo that either because as much as
you know I've been the Rascal through
the years and thrown in you know little
aside just through the over under and
all of the rest and I've Loved I've
loved doing that so I mean that was
coming into the the back door the side
door I can come in the front door right
now
welcome but but if you start doing that
I you know look a lot of people bet on
the game do certain things maybe bet
whether it's run past whatever
um no but I I I still think the vast
majority of the audience is not into
that you can have some fun with it uh
you can talk about it in terms of what
sort of an upset this is or how unusual
something is but to make that a big part
of the game no I I'm not going to go
there
when's the first time you refer to Kirk
as Chris
how about the first time that he refers
to me as Chris
we got doodling Chris is here don't
forget Chris Fowler yeah yeah we each
work with the Chris mine doesn't have an
H uh minus c-r-i-s is a c h r i s when's
the first time uh that's a good question
but I will tell you this I did 20 years
of Monday Night Football
I did 16 years of Sunday and I got to
tell you the first few years on Sunday I
cannot believe I didn't say Monday Night
Football I can't believe it but it was
always there in my brain and even in
conversations with people through the
years I would refer to my show as Monday
night excuse me Sunday Night Football
it never happened on the air for some
crazy reason
so I I would say the over under is uh
it may happen now I mean I'm at a
different point in life and everything I
give it six I give it six games
uh great to talk to you I hope the golf
game is good out it stinks so what can I
tell you Dave you know what kind of you
gotta swing through it for me give me
give me a swing thread I've got like 900
in my iPhone
how about most when you swing
yeah when you take it back yes Johnny
Miller
oh for crying out loud so
um well you do you can do anybody with
with two syllables right yeah Shaquille
oh new yes would that work too yes yes
Daniel Tempo Patrick Tempo Tempo you
know what that's philosophical Miller
I need I need you know like the right
elbow at a 20. no no no no no no no no
you don't need that I understand no no
no no Dan Dan there's only one thing
that's going to make my golf game better
a lobotomy because your brain gets in
the way you know that you know what
screws up how about this how about this
thinking Chris fuamatu mama
ah that would be Barclays that would be
marketing that's right he's got he's
gotten so much better I know I know I
know I can't go back to Tahoe last year
I finished behind him seriously oh yeah
yeah it wasn't last but you know but he
he's I mean even this year he had eight
nine ten guys behind him yeah at Tahoe
who's the worst golfer who's the worst
celebrity golfer out there
well you may be looking at him uh I
don't know that the celebrity
necessarily falls into that but you know
we've got a lot of actors we get we have
some some good golfers some of the
tennis players are fantastic of course
hockey guys the hockey guys are terrific
yeah we want to know who's the bad guy
like uh
who finished behind you
oh in uh in Tahoe yeah well CeCe
Sabathia did but he withdrew the last
day okay
there were a couple of other references
thank God for Sushi Boy I was you know
I'll tell you what the most
nerve-wracking thing in that tournament
is you know when you know you're behind
Barclay you can't catch on it oh God
humiliation I understand
uh good to talk to you as always and uh
we'll uh we'll check in with you here
during the season okay thank you buddy
you bet that's uh Al Michaels Hall of
Fame broadcaster Amazon Thursday night
play-by-play with Kirk Herbstreit